look Thailand 2019 my name is spying on
gob the legend mark man we're in Group D
action right now and it's looking really
really interesting it is looking very
very interesting indeed it you guys can
see right now I mean it's been pretty
clean I mean a lot of the matches have
been you know very straightforward - OH
- oh but they still been hard fought
matches right now no be from Japan and
Hawaii from Pakistan sit at the top of
Group D where it's a fight right now to
figure out who will be getting out but I
mean if I were to bet if I was someone
that would wager it would be one of
those guys those guys are playing
incredibly but still not over we still
have some matches the leader right now
on the leaderboard I should say with no
be going up against rock dragons Chanel
yeah if Chanel loses this he is he is
out of the tournament now is that you
know especially since how how good no
bianna ways are doing points-wise in
this group so Chanel definitely to win
this but man listen I mean I want to
talk about Novi man like Nobby we store
it in the interview that we had just
earlier on stream where you spoke about
you know Japan and you know trying to
get the conversation shifted towards
Japan again you know he wants to get
Japanese players in Taipei wants to win
the Tekken World Tour it's great right
yeah it's not just about him it's about
his region his country pride and he's
been a pillar of the Japanese Tekken
community right for how long he's been
the guy if you think about Japan when
you think about Japan second you think
about Dobey right yeah so I mean he's
not just carrying the hopes of himself
like personally he's count the hopes of
Japan on him to bring but he'll make
Japan great again you know so to speak
and a waste is kind of the same thing as
waste the only remaining Pakistani
player and that's one of the reasons why
I think they're doing so well I mean
it's quite the challenge I mean if he's
able to make it in to our top eight that
would mean the three Japanese players in
the top eight but we'll see I mean
already qualified we have I believe
Chikara in on the winners side and we
also have double on the winner side yeah
the Japanese fans getting very very well
the hair we've got a Lisa versus
Draganov it's gonna be Chanel versus
Novi Korea Japan and this is pushing
nails tormal life right here you cannot
lose this match
nobody's been using his poke so well
move choices and everything that down to
has been that has it hardly been blocked
as well very very good tracking could be
an issue for Chanel or someone who likes
to move laterally to the left and right
let's see find who's gonna take it yeah
but I mean the way Toby's been playing
this man has been on firing he has been
just dominant in every single set that
we've seen a play so far oh my god the
picked up all man in the conversions an
adjustment look at that hasn't been the
one what's he gonna do this is how his
matches have been going it just be out
of nowhere
nobody has a huge light fleet what's
gonna happen help he ended up winning
yeah life lead after life leave it's
like everything he's doing is working
yeah that's the thing even changed his
outfit all right here we go it's the
punish their 2-1 three yeah can you
shoot the string down to again there's
such a good low but nice to talk there
from Chanel get something on the board
take it to the rule oh yeah get some
extra damage out of it here let's see
what he does but again no beat not
afraid to fight away from it
oh wow gets the conversion will kind of
messed out face okay so coming out of it
rage I bet it went up your Chanel oh the
downfall to this should be dead with the
right combo into the rage arch and
that's gonna connect chainsaws out let's
shoot some missiles
keeping it simple here we go Chanel on
the board
yeah one round a piece now fine I mean
nobody was still pretty dominant there
that last round it just chanel got that
key hit at the very end again
just harassing his opponent there with
it down - yeah again the second here
back one two done gets punished with the
wall standing - now pushed at the wall
one more time
yeah she's now definitely ducking
strings very Rohan just keeping him in
the game I like it there he does have
the life leavings you have to be careful
and that's a nice pun oh my god
oh is that it all I don't I think the
rage art woulda killed put the tote
option down and that's crazy he went for
the trooper older that does have some
crush window later on but man that would
have been a crazy meeting was able to
get that yeah 22 once again down to the
timing so judge and actually ducked that
but cop I'd like to find it down - nice
good presence of mind they're able to
put the brakes on it again a huge lead
from Nobby surprise surprise oh my god
it's likely his folks are on point today
everything is working final round hair
in the first cake
oh the beat down throw important
pressing a bun
maybe tried to go for the power crush
yeah all in a pick counter hit the
follow up yeah nice damage there from
Chanel aside to rush it but
unfortunately there the get up kick okay
go to the mid such a simple place our
hair combed over you trying to go for
the wall bounce yeah
one of the quickest wall belts into the
game so good huge change garden season
three
oh the late second hit the follow up
here it goes to the throw still
continuing with that same pressure race
try spent resources like garden fix up
want us to throw broken get off me heavy
Kapow crushed punished
Oh what there's the right here I is so
good with landing that move man no the
don't B's crazy how many times you see
them finish the round with the raised
right yeah it's it's been it's been
working out for him I mean might as well
right
nope a man possessed all right we're
going into the classic the infinite
stage here infinite is your to five
matches in a row mark no B has one he's
untouchable right now he is untouchable
I will not be surprised if he makes it
out here on the winter side yeah but I
mean it's also excites me to see that
matchup that we might be seeing pretty
soon yeah you know that's demonic
matchup in the corner
anyways into the matchup low profile
step up to the seed one all right
starting it off let's see what happens
here
yeah oh this is new yeah i sidestepped
they're able to get the launch here and
I like that but you know that's
something that he hasn't been using in
any of the matchups against his opponent
that down for two
yeah the thoughtful T is so good catch
your opponent running into it full
launcher don't you once again catches
Chanel sidestepping I was talking about
now down to such good track in the whole
water step there but unable to get any
damage out of it there about even on
life let's see what happens here no duck
nice punish good okay as well oh my god
it goes for the wall 94 nobody once
again making all the right decisions
yeah this is a nobody's feeling of
something he is getting the right reads
the right mix ups and the conversions
look at that off the float get some
extra damage there the extension oh my
god
nice damage there let's check that me
that's the second time we've seen and
I'll do that too so new shakes you got
in season in season three really really
good no cha oh we're ready for those
yeah challenging the down to now gets
the low power but this is the danger
zone this is where nobody has really
started to shine in a lot of the matches
but hate that's I'm not able to pull
anything out with the rage yeah I think
that what she now needs to do is try to
get nobody to doubt is over where you go
do is challenge on roads because the
down to covers so many options it gives
you damage it gives you pressure but it
also catches you sizes as well and you
can neutralize that maybe get some
design and that's the thing - he is so
brilliant with his use of the mix-up
after down to land yeah it's so scary
because what's he need is even a size if
he's gonna down to again he's gonna go
for low goal to interrupt anything
there's so many options and he's been
getting the right read more often than
not exactly so struck power crush
punished have no be Oh kind of looking
god I'm looking let me wrap my legs
around you
just like that nobody moves on this F
way once again to take the match to 200
nice I look at the big hit the follow up
here if Chanel loses as he is out of the
tournament
yeah all you can do left is play spoiler
right ruin somebody's day but right now
nobody is ruining everyone's day in his
path oh my god what we'll do it running
- I'd love to finish it though B once
again with another - oh [ __ ] now his
second world tour 2019 comes to an end
here in Bangkok Thailand water
personality what an amazing player but
man you know it's sad the way you went
up up an amazing thing either way that's
the thing I mean we have so many
favorite players more than just 20 that
are here in the finals it but it's hard
I mean you can't see not all of them can
get into the topping yeah it's sad man
someone has to do is and this time it
was Chanel on his birthday as well as to
start come on man rainy but you know no
of you looking strong last six matches
in a row now my knees three and oh he's
looking at touchable I mean just seeing
the way he's playing seeing the way he's
adjusting I mean if I could shift over
my pick now I would be Nobi Nobi is
playing like a madman yeah if we saw the
form this man is in and if you just look
at the grips man top
in groupie number one Chickering in
group c number one no B in Group D
number one these Japanese players out
here to do some damage they had to prove
a point
why is ever talk about Pakistan Japan is
what you need to be talking about so our
next match coming up here it's gonna be
a beast low high vs Jimmy J Tran both of
these guys definitely need a win
Jimmy's yet to find one it's gonna be a
very interesting match
well these players getting ready and
meant it's been a rough driving this is
uh I mean this is probably one of the
toughest pools it's the death pool if
you guys think about the poor pools this
was the death floor right yeah of course
low high getting ready for his matchup
let's listen to what he had to say
earlier today get the money you'd okay
tremendous and how much power and I
think I gamma tell you what tomorrow sir
oh man
Fisher man I mean I put many many times
in monster events and even in local
tournaments in Korea you know me has
been the guy that has his number right
and low high in order to prove to
himself that he is improving that you
know to get over that I'll have that
hurdle to kind of the way that me did
with our salon today you know he wants
to get that win and me is gonna be in
the top eight so if interested to see if
no high can make it in there to meet him
and get his match but first he's gonna
have to go through one of America's
finest in Jimmy J Tran now I know that
lohi actually used to play Brian himself
he's actually very comfortable in the
matchup of swing versus sonship earlier
this year and it was really really
comfortable but obviously this Jimmy J
trying to ease the best Brian in the
world one of the best minds in the world
it's a different Brian yeah we'll see
how this gonna play out of course we are
in the Dragon's nest first the two
matches it's gonna be Brian fury and
Shaheen kind of like what we expected
here and say yep okay the mains all
around here we go one USA versus Korea
Jimmy J versus low hi
are nice able to open up early on goes
for the oh nice jab challenge I like it
ok don't break on the one pursuit oh
there's some good okie opportunity hair
go for the mid oh no high with a big
counter in the follow-up gets the
counter here yep nice guaranteed one hit
left for low high to take the first
round there it is goes for the lot
yeah like the patience for both of these
players obviously making everyone think
about what they're gonna be doing yeah
okay Jimmy J just waiting for something
waiting for an opportunity punish try to
work his way in able to get the punish
there yes very hard to punish to open
with but no hi package basic yeah has
such an active window word where it
could hit you so you got to be scared of
it
yeah alright back one here continue with
the pressure gets a counter hit the
follow-up you might be able to close it
out yeah that will be H lower height to
around up have as a Jimmy J three fine
low high seemingly in cruise control
right now Jimmy's gonna have to start
fighting back
yeah like I said you know low high in
plays Brian himself quite often know is
that much up very welcome to older games
have you got Jimmy J win account
Savannah rebus war
yeah and this could be the change at
he's pushing towards the other side of
the stage nice down to any other hit or
four streams
oh he wasn't ready for the big stuff
can't see those and not instead that the
day of the lost leader Jimmy J on the
board yeah able to get it there that's
one way to start it
the follow up here what's gonna do all
the slides they're coming out yep
guaranteed hit the floor Oh what the
Vulcan follow up here what's gonna do Oh
Andy was ready for it yeah ready with
that punish okay through this wall
keeping him out lo hice choosing the
player very close range Jimmy J doesn't
want to have it put in the down for it
too this could be it it's gonna hurt not
enough to kill back yeah pretty dominant
there from low I bet mmm yeah definitely
like I said he knows this matchup I've
seen in versus multiple Brian players
and he always does so well if there is a
match of that I would say he does like
over every other matchup is this one
yeah former uh he used the main Brian I
believe in tag to his Laura he's like
Brian and a la uh-huh yeah smack a [ __ ]
tour job as an all sorts but yeah Jimmy
J's in that in that situation as well
he's lost five matches in a row if he
loses this set he is also going to be
out mark that's not what people want to
man the fan favorite the People's Champ
here Jimmy J Tran going to his Jeep Corp
helipad the classic mmm-hmm alright guys
here we go
two great players in both Jimmy J
Trenton low I battling seems people to
take it low high up 1-0 right now and I
say g1j can bring it back he's gonna
have to change something up definitely
there's no high looks in cruise control
just like you said yeah that's fine just
came out of nowhere able to clip his
legs and look at this low high width and
aggression he is rushing down Jimmy Joe
by the big counter he'd only Trump
that's not what he wanted nice job I
love I take school advise you to obey
and guess I Brown of the board Jimmy J
it's now or never
Oh looking for that opportunity gets a
nice punish there with a 4-3 punish nice
[Music]
nice orbital Neal this is gonna hurt
take it to the pool good okie as well oh
he challenged him able to get the hit
uh-huh and he's in range is gonna be
very very dangerous gets the second hit
confirmation he cooked up sick do a port
there first time I've seen it delay that
much still hit almost our practice that
right now yeah almost hit the monitor
all right you me now Pocono right this
is what not to see Matt just going
through this own pokes all big
counter-hit there with the three plus
four this is gonna hurt has the wall
tried to go for the extra damage yeah he
thought he was hiding up on the display
unable to get it though yeah
and the rage Isaac bedsloe has an
opportunity here for him now yeah coast
to coast
what's the mix-up it goes for the chop
again yeah cross frames range available
he was able to thread the needle with
that down back to and look at that low
high one round away here from ending gbt
trance chances in the tournament look at
the pressure from low I stayed in close
range poke it away poke it away count it
once again brats the follow-up here
Jamie's he's just outside of range but
also outside of kill he's yet to be
careful
oh my god one pixel left now whenever
goes for the rage drive gonna be low
high taking it to over Jimmy J ending
his second world war 2019 here in
Bangkok Thailand are the finals but man
one amazing plan again man we hate to
see it but you know someone has to be
the winner and this time it was you I
use low high what dominating performance
in that Brian matchup low high of course
going off we're gonna get our next
matchup on stage but man there are so
many crazy matches that are coming up I
mean this last pull you know there were
so many nail fighters right early on I
mean these matches have been close but
man they've been very dominated as well
yeah yeah it's been very one-sided it's
a bit different from the other pools
right when you look to this pool we have
killer after killer but it has been very
one-sided matches so yeah I'll have a
look at the group C Group D know B and
OS at the top there no me at three and
oh yeah having not dropped a single
match same with the way as to a no not
dropped a single match low high two and
one
so I mean low hostile in it Chanel and
Jimmy unfortunately are out of the
contention here for the second world
tour but low high still fighting yeah I
think this is gonna be a very important
one to kind of find out who will be
getting out on the winners side yes so
we have and you know nobody was talking
about earlier wanting to make Japan
great again the focus currently being on
Pakistan's
they want to do or especially him wants
to be able to show the world that Japan
is still a force to be reckoned with
he's gonna have his shot here
Malcolm liking it man he's gonna have a
shot here it's a Hamas anobii from Japan
going up against genuine gaming Zoe's
honey from Pakistan undefeated versus
undefeated Pakistan vs. Japan nobody
trying to shift the way to contention
for bucks on over to Japan Oh cheering
it sounds like they say no robando they
say honey they could go either way you
got to ride that wave let it go like oh
yeah their cheer for me cheer for me
both these players yeah yeah I'm feeling
good I've never had anyone cheer for me
like that that's cool the Aussies out
here man I just got some tweets as well
from you guys in the land down under
shout out to you man
current on the shrimp on the barbie
doing force back oh really oh the crowd
all right here we go undefeated versus
undefeated this is why I like to see
Japan vs. Pakistan this is a road back
from every Cup in Malaysia where nobody
to the first two games so convincing
yeah and then away it sports back three
matches straight but mark this is a
first two - hell yeah and that
tournament you know obviously nobody
ended up getting third place to put all
whites really put himself out on the map
and he ended up beating Nobby and me in
the grand final yes and that's really
where everyone started to take notice I
mean obviously as many players at least
within Pakistan and within the circle
that knew about the players they knew
what's going on yes for water yes okay
so got to make sure you're hydrated
hydration is important man especially if
you're gonna be funneling out these
crazy combos so yeah like you like you
said mark man nobody was saying that he
wants to ship that attention towards the
Japan to Japan now and prove that they
are the best in the world and what a way
to do it then to go for and all in the
group and beating the person that
everyone is talking about a where Sonny
genuine gaming this is such an important
match guys watching a hopefully share
the stream and let every know everyone
know what's going on it's gonna be a
banger all right here we go this is to
decide a lot of things but right now of
course who is gonna get the lead here in
Pool D it is the matchup we have
expected it is dragon are versus Akuma
oh boy oh boy yeah and if you're here in
the crowd make sure you guys don't go
anywhere there's a lot of crazy stuff
that's about to pop off I'm super
excited this is the Tekken World Tour
Finals who is gonna get into our top
eight we'll have to wait and see how it
goes
Noby buses are less
let me hey you guys let's go ohoho we've
got the we're punished right away did
not do anything with it buddy he made my
heart stop happy by heart stuff someone
give them the complimentary meter give
them both meter nice slow very old man
see this is what we're talking about it
nobody's been playing out of his mind
who has been playing better out of the
two we're about to find out
Wow - paroled yes both of you guys I
left defeated right now to have a single
talk a single match oh yeah oh no punish
of the low kick though yeah he doesn't
have meter though so it's not as scary
with nobody's gonna have to extinguish
this right away and it's just like you
said Bob it's the perfect time to get
that round on the board but Akuma does
not have meat on now might have to
change his plan here oh my gosh the work
punishes were ready he's gonna get the
wall as well yep good diamond check it
he got some goodies at me as well tries
to keep him at the wall but no be able
to roll away here
oh and again he doesn't have meter so
nobody's gonna probably start to rush
him down
Oh brilliant sighs we'll plug that
running to another opportunity down to
now we can use it
ah ha that was a kind of hit follow up
here what you're gonna do
oh look is that the white is really
taking it back tie it up on rounds the
only faster looking like he's not even
over yet the Berber did you love her you
half of Novi galaxy great Reed's right
now
oh my god that was the right reaction
there's puts a stop to the momentum the
Japanese are so loud right now let me
have you guys for my straining [ __ ]
song where are you back
oh he drops a combo rare drops here for
Moyes honey no duck but duck doesn't
matter he gets on board for continuing
with the damage oh my gosh Toby's
playing out of his mind
Oh Nobita - no me - yet able to use the
fireball to continue with that spacing
yes he's trying to build some Mita try
some are going to do oh the demon flip
throw he has the meter now Oh slow
motion for me down for for Toby once
again making the right decision oh and
he's still able to convert there outside
of the air uh-huh home button they'll be
playing at anybody get the fountain this
is gonna hurt he might get another wall
oh he's a nice boy oh oh this is gonna
be big nothing that beat her though yeah
doesn't have money but he does have rage
that is true he's not gonna spend it now
running one wave down to another one to
the law no B is playing like a man
possessed look at a crowd that loving it
they are loving it Oh where's honey then
they go to the state selects yo no bees
you're always on some stuff right now
and a voice on bro with your piss test
I'll take two separate and oh right now
no be on the crowd very much in favor no
be at this moment what do you think his
son is thinking about right now
they'll be son can we call them till we
get him on the line
son of Dobie are you happy for your dad
let's see if she finishes it off though
the work is not done don't you got child
support to pay nobody's trying to get
that money might I remind you guys
$250,000 on the line this day will go be
finish this match and go 800 in matches
if his pool of killers unprecedented
right absolutely unbelievable
oh man that was big nice plot though he
was ready for it are you kind of looking
look at my foot [ __ ] what's happening
what's happening Romi is ascending maybe
to the throne who knows he's playing
like a mad man look at that puts up it
to rage
what's he gonna do now nice confirmation
you trying to make Japan cry yet oh man
he's already done this guy oh man the
whole that damned he got that meter just
in time yes
right awareness OS good breaking them up
this to counter hit
oh gosh off okapi goes for the fall up
here having an opportunity get gets it
this time you might be able to get the
wall no he drops the cobble unfortunate
you should get the screw what if Miss I
don't believe it
Baga potash he was ready that his boat
funny she brought no he will take the
round of the second match these guys
going back and forth alright it's not
going down without a fight
he's cheering that God really back up
really hard now away pressure on the
line jumps over him outside of range
nights for to there gets a knockdown
here again yes meter now this is where
it's gonna be scary for nobody nights
with punish uh-huh he's gone barmy has a
bright cat for very very carefully no
joke of a string man yes he is doing the
right things with all these folks here
but you know no be not trying to get
into any trouble here Oh Manuel Oh Perry
and he's still using the down soon with
full confidence but won't my son you
with the confirmation two rounds to one
I didn't justify golf bar me to that as
well coming into this next round
is he gonna be the first player to take
a match on for Nova tonight it might be
I forget the down three clean here we go
hey they get to the wall the reset he
gets a pickup oh boy this is gonna hurt
oh my gosh he is a sitting duck right
now that's where a kuma was this whole
time he was here in Pool D but man oh
man going down to the final match
between these two is similar to what we
saw in Malaysia where they went down to
the wire table the crowd is super
intense what we're gonna get Bob you
know why there's a grandmas I can see
tasty Steven the crowd he's going nuts
in the middle over there tell them to
save some energy yes new commentary
later genuine gaming vs. your boss on
Japan vs. Pakistan
this is such a report back all right
guys it comes down to this who is gonna
be able to make it out oh my gosh we're
going to the Forgotten Realms the party
stage more damage for every one you get
some damage you get some damage everyone
damage alright it's all who's gonna get
the hit though that's the thing who is
gonna get the launch who is gonna
capitalize yeah absolutely and you know
dragon or gets really good options on
this because he's up for four becomes a
launcher
you know actually gets a full combo from
a lot of his moves like it doesn't
normally do fine alright starting it off
the incisive match between these two
amazing players Japan vs. Pakistan yep
poking away hair where's Sonny trying to
build up that meter did it this year the
game but that's why I was talking about
the outboard for is that fully launched
up on this page yeah and he's able to
convert here gets full sidewall stun oh
man engine look at this Nobby with the
lead right now
all the whit punish you got half meter
yet though sweet I've noticed here my
son he really wants to start building up
the meter early on he's been way more
aggressive than he's been in the past
two matches so far yet man that's
another one up for four fully launched a
from tobe gonna take the first round in
this final game
and they'll be really holding it down
right now representing hard for his home
country that is the reason why he
existed well yeah both these guys
reprographic hard for their respective
countries away the only Fox INF guess
account ahead 444 oh this is gonna hurt
he's gonna go downstairs
what's the follow-up what's he into
affordable pudding no he goes for the
standing to mix up oh he almost had him
but nice delay tech there from novi
instant running to Novi Oh sunny -
there's a follow-up what's he gonna do
go straight down to County hit you had
another one very scared to do it at this
juncture though because if you get too
blocked once it might be it look at that
no be one round away he wants to secure
a winner slight burn down - that's one
way to extinguish the flame yeah look at
this damage incoming away it's a bit the
reverse beef right now oh he caught he
kept him there
the spring kick was coming nice cheese
this setup here the right positioning I
can't do this always honey stays the
light bringing out all the sauce right
now ten hits using everything any new
look at it he's built up so much meter
in that sequence as well no fear for a
honey but nice dog Harry had from dovey
nobody wants to end it here hey he's
looking for it he's one round away all
the counter hit y'all Ford one able of
jab him in the rib booth
down to again closing so many issues
with everyone in the pool running to
flush frames advantage again with the
Ford Fort Worth he's trying to fish for
the big hit he doesn't even flip
afterwards he dropped it takes it
undefeated so far I'm the defeated for
Oh in this pool he will move on to top
eight in the winner's bracket away Sonny
dropped the fumble at the end and nobody
took full advantage Japan
insane absolute insanity no B he's a man
on a mission hey Mark a man on a mission
but it's not over yet mind we have to
move on we must move on that's crazy
guys this is second this is amazing this
is taken I hope you guys are enjoying
this cuz we still have more matches
coming up but now this is top who is
gonna get out on the loser side I don't
know it's gonna be too hard to tell
because you know two of these guys are
in contention we have a white honey in
low hi yes and right now that are
currently tied up I remember low high
was saying that look he he had a target
on her waist his head every time they've
played a waist has beaten him yeah I
believe but low high knows the Akuma
match up so well as we saw him do by
taking our octave but and you know doing
really well versus other Akuma players
so low high really wants that match
that's gonna be crazy mark that will be
the match to decide who moves on and we
could have zero Pakistanis in the top
eight here yeah and this is I mean this
is what everyone was saying like you
know Pakistan is gonna take over the TWC
finals they're gonna come in through the
LCQ yeah they're gonna dominate in the
pool bracket which I mean what's a fair
a fair guess right yeah but to have no
one in the top it would be crazy
especially with how much dominance
they've really shown this year you can
clearly see from just Nobby man that the
preparation that these guys have been
doing there are so many Japanese place
in the winner starters top 8 but we must
move on here we have
versus America Jimmy J versus Chanel
that both these guys are out of the
tournament
but there's still a lot of pride on the
line here where the Tucker Balto finals
here in Bangkok 2019 it's a lot to play
for
oh he picks eliza going away from elisa
for the first time here hmm
in tournament play well it hasn't worked
for him he hasn't got a win on the board
yet so you know God try something
different
alright last day on earth last turbit of
the day yeah last match for both of
these players let's see how it's gonna
work out nice opening combo here from
Chanel you should be able to get the
wall here continue with more pressure
thank you very very it goes to be here
none of these guys want to go home to 0
and 4 okay side kick Wow it's a counter
hit that should be the first fraction
you know on the board you know starting
off strong here with the character
switch nice able to get the same for
Jimmy looking for an opportunity the
thing is he does have the right state
position right now obviously with
Chanel's back to the wall you have to be
very careful here especially with you
forgetting he's so used to Brian those
lanes again Steve oh you have force but
you see it's Chanel defy all these guy
kicks you're seeing that Plus on block
as well so Jimmy can't really swing
after them he's got a kind of just move
away from it possible yeah kind of find
his way and maneuver his way in
yeah oh oh that's gonna hurt side wall
side still oh I thought I was gonna get
another conversion I was unfortunate it
wasn't a clean water about two bars hope
to work with from Chanel one pics of the
healthcare for Jimmy J trade both guys
rate the dark weave
and right now chanel up to round two
zero here okay usually those type kicks
he does have meter as well meter really
does allow to extend his combo damage
and the potential for starting off the
moves against the x-type kick yes they
drag the hunch as well so much
yes slash twenty by the wall so damaging
and scary interesting try to buy his way
back but just like you mentioned monsta
x diet kicks like a good move will be
very close to death yeah
able to push schwartz other side of the
states while sliver of life left for
jimmy he's gonna have to be careful here
but uses his last bar meat system assert
a mix-up and [ __ ] now three round
straight jimmy not looking so good i
love a wishing l does this stuff of
course if you guys are tuning in right
now this is pool d this is the last
group-stage of the day before we get
into our topic we already have one of
our players in we're trying to find out
who will be making it from blue site
unfortunately it'll be neither one of
these two players yeah it's gonna be the
next matchup after this but we still
want to see how this one plays out to
world-class players going at it yeah
absolutely
oh boy Jimmy J is he gonna go home oh
and for hair he hasn't won a single
match not a single match here in this
pool and it is a pool of death as well
he wanted it I mean this is the the pool
he put himself into yes
each one is a challenge itself let's see
if you can bring it back
starting it off again goes for the
nosebleed that was made safe as well and
in this season really really good move
there from Eliza yeah some of the
changes I mean one of the positive
changes I would say depending on who you
talk to prim the community but anyway
dive kicks again yes
nice tonight gonna get full couple hey
hey just gonna hurt what's the mix-up it
goes for any get though he misses the
mark breaker he's I can unless you know
back in he's always got Barbie off me
get chatting on the board finally his
first round to they're able to use that
punch sequence at the very end there
that has so many layers of makes up if
you think about it yeah all right now
Jimmy sorry to chop away at the legs
looking for that opening Oh in a big
counter hit yes is he gonna get the
other wall is that what he's aiming for
Jewish post just short there chanel go
with a life deficit trying to work his
way back water come I've never seen that
before
oh yeah expended that meter use yeah now
he's gonna have a nice to mix up
opportunity at the wall here oh you have
a good patient for Jimmy's to stay on
the floor that he's gonna get hit by the
picks up that opportunity nice slow very
able to close it out now Jimmy turning
around two straight rounds here for him
damn complete turnaround half of Jimmy o
444 big chunk of damage
is Jimmy gonna get his first match on
the board hair in this group D to Bosnia
to work rib gets a counter hit
Oh
that's the setup and [ __ ] now odds is
back yeah quite fierce going down
without a fight that setup was sick and
he still has meter as well it's you if
he's able to employ it in some kind yeah
I mean this is a pretty big stage
especially with the walls broken but I
mean both of these characters have that
wall carry yeah oh nice inter up there
from Jimmy Jimmy starting to fight back
gets a nice float here pushing back the
other way
this could be it this could be it what's
the mix-up Oh got to be careful Jimmy
looking the ticket and he does tying it
up one match apiece yes bus right the
first match with Jimmy J Tran here I can
you finish the set though can he finish
it as a Chanel I got to assume that she
now is gonna be going to an infinite
stage unless he changes character
anything is on the character selection
you think he's going for the classic
always going for the Safina looks like
this is a V that is locked in all right
here we go
and he actually quite simple sex as well
double whammy
that is a the best of luck I guess happy
birthday Chanel yeah right here we go
final match that these two are gonna
play here in Bangkok Thailand for the
Tekken World Tour Finals 2019 who is
going to take it
let's get into it fight Safina I carried
us all about movement for the best back
- it became really really good sidewalk
yeah that's the thing - especially with
you know a player like Chanel who is
always excelled in moving as we've seen
it time and again with his character
with ELISA but now even more so with
Safina yeah
you know Jimmy recently lost the
tournament in the u.s. against shadows
of FINA so I know for a fact he's
probably done his homework in this
matchup
you have to do your homework in this
match because she has thoughts is man
you have to know about what you have to
do is a situation scientist in so many
weird situational moves that can go feed
other moves as well the call doesn't
matter going finishes gets the counter
hit yeah adoption Holly move locked and
loaded here we go Jimmy fighting back
what's he gonna do here okay here we go
side set poked it away big whip down the
back one and a nice punishment Chanel
opportunity City nice gets the followed
there that made that a little bit easier
to do here since the recent update yes
he is in rape though is he gonna go for
the raid drive mixup what's gonna happen
gotta finish a few Jimmy to finish your
food all the cross drive and he's able
to land they hit their crazy stuff
they're from Chanel we do see a lot
right when you have a massive life do
you tend to be a bit more passive
because you don't take any risks but it
was your opponent to get back in well
that's a big dude is that great mental
block I mean you gotta think like other
this guy is gonna party I'm gonna just
stand here and be saved right that all
these lows you can hit my like every
local yeah it's crazy
Oh
that is home workout this matchup Jimmy
j.chan yeah and you know Jenelle is cool
I'm chillin I'm not pressing any buttons
no tech girls for me it's my birthday my
trying to lose it just like that Jimmy J
boobs onto set point fight to get his
first match hey Rudy nobody wants to go
home oh and poor challenger here
guaranteed stop good move ahead we
should know now he's the one with a
massive taki doesn't mean taking a
massive risks waiting for an opportunity
to punish back what could have been torn
could have been Javed is my small team
I'm just looking for this opportunity
they'll just very content with the
movement here trying to stay away stand
all my gosh that was the right time to
do it down for two
I just like that one guys a final final
round in the back one who is gonna take
it who is gonna go home oh and for it
this all what a snap there really opened
up the opportunity for himself and Jimmy
with a slight life lead here but again
Chanel starting to back up Oh put the
delay yeah once again I love it now 60%
off
[Music]
nice you try to get a whiff punished
there yeah just outraged huge leave now
for Jimmy G H and what a lo Perry I like
it
great read that from Chanel got rage
yeah the running people's for the follow
up here what's gonna happen to has rage
is to still go either way or be whipped
and Jimmy J will take the match a little
bit of consolation for him hair will go
home one and three Chanel oh and a four
happy birthday to you that is not the
best birthday present but you know still
you know to be able to actually get to
the stage was is a feat minute within
itself and celebrate with your friends
and community here in Thailand yeah
celebrating the game that we all love as
well as to us what it's all about - what
is all about but now walk decisive match
time are you ready for this business
time business time I'm all about the
business man we have a very decisive
match that's going to be coming up it's
gonna be you I use low hi from South
Korea going up against genuine gaming's
on Weiss honey from Pakistan and this
match this particular match is gonna
decide who is gonna get into topping
right so I believe what's the situation
here because it is it's it's a pure set
whoever wins a set oh yeah alright okay
cool
these guys are shooting it who's gonna
get the side and it's like no high
ticket
you're gonna get it preferred side here
you are you versus genuine gaming you
know I must say - I would I don't know a
bit of spice to this mark spice it up
I'm gonna spice up a little bit yeah so
you know drew made a tweet on shots -
drew you are you to read it to you on
Twitter saying you know oh you know
these genuine gaming guys are good but
you know don't forget oh wait you know
low high beats are cheap I saw that a
few weeks ago yeah and then genuine
gaming replied with the picture of a
waist honey with the trophy Dubai so
there is a little bit of a thing between
Gigi and you are you so you know yeah
but that's let the orgs [ __ ] let the
players talk right now I want to see
this these two players obviously they've
have had some history together right
mm-hmm
they played each other before
I think that a race honey has not lost
to him it's been very close I forgot I
think it was Tokyo where they played at
top 32 winner side and a waist honey
beaten but it was a very breaker it was
supposed he did the best out of every
non Pakistani player to put at least put
a threat here into his run into the
championship yeah just like we mentioned
earlier I know hi did the artist but
actually the by masters as well correct
but it really showed that he went back
to the lab study that cumin match up yes
but one Akuma is not the same as another
it's very very true mad but I'm
expecting a very close match you are you
versus Gigi Fox on visit Korea the
winner of this match is gonna make it
into our top eight the final match of
the group stages guys yeah and it's
really really going to affect how our
Tommy plays out I mean I'm always all
for a variety in terms of region country
representation and character
representation I don't know man it's
tough I'm kind of rooting here for a
while yeah it'd be good to have some
extra representation man he's the final
Pakistani but he's gonna have to go
through a beast in low high someone who
is so practiced in the Akuma matchup it
all comes down to this the final match
of the group stages here at second well
tour finals well this is what people
have been training for they want to be
able to represent in the finals and this
is their chance only one of these two
players will move on oh my god let's go
I'm excited Shaheen vs. Akuma first two
action
Pakistan vs. Korea here we go erase the
two nice starts it off with the wasps 84
again this is the time where you want to
employ the dominant you do not want
Akuma he got the size throw you don't
know what Akuma to have that meter early
on absolutely
okay Paul up here nice punish again
actually punish that with the chops nice
back to that's a tracking attack the
keffiyeh coming off straight away he's
threatening that down for two trying to
tell a waste ecologist wanted to be in
close range as you like and right now I
mean it's it's too tough to say I mean
right now you just built that meter is
this is where it's gonna get scary yes
now you see a race honey just chilling a
little bit doesn't want to run to the
down for to nothing then let no hide
back in it and there we go the race
Drive that should be the round Hey
oh it wasn't enough the X dragon puts
what's he gonna do made option oh my oh
he was ready he stayed out of range and
it was able to whip punish that but man
what up exchange there yes remember guys
loser of this is out of the tournament
winner is it through top eight or they
traded blows there huh but still a look
at this positioning or why honey gets
the pop there you trying to jab him out
of it yeah can't do that the pop beats
it yeah early bomb you got to be careful
oh that's one way to deal with the big
sup of doing it or not doing it yeah but
geez look at a white honey right now two
rounds straight low eyes gonna have to
dig deep he is gonna have to dig deeper
right now he's able to deal with Akuma
no meter yeah yes absolutely it could be
a little bit more reckless but the meter
is slowly but surely building up there
we go nice to jack
should hit the wall hair Hey
the follow-up here what's gonna happen
yeah I didn't get full combat the water
fortune either low woofs lat there's so
much good stuff happening yeah
both these guys always ready with their
with punishes can't make a single
mistake slide you then trying to get
that wall positioning running one pushes
him into the middle one bar of meter 18
seconds left let's talk knows better
standing to but no fire will confirm
yeah I didn't get the confirmation and
you know that's usually his thing that's
his bread and butter
oh my god he's gonna launch up hot kick
it have you got low height finally on
the board
oh and he's gonna get that he's gonna
catch in down to and this should go
towards the corner this is very
dangerous for low height nice keep
something what's gonna do with it
where's the pressure no punish oh just
let that low high switch positions gets
a war zone
oh man look at this pressure it's insane
they're so tight the five yeah fighting
back and again he gets to be very
careful because he does have meter low I
looking to take this cell final round
what you can do one more mix let me do
it oh wow work rush
then again to coast range good back that
stay from low high both dices rage down
three and again so much on the line here
to get into top eight only one of these
two players I give the GG guys going
nuts in the crowd they love with it they
are loving it and I hope you guys are
home or as well this it all comes down
to this now you can see the stress in
low height space usually so calm and
collected but it all comes down to this
he's up 1-0 he is in good position I
mean this is the best position you could
be in going to the second match right
yeah but oh we're going to the classic
we are going to know wall stage the
infinite of your yes the stage of choice
versus an Akuma player hope you don't
mind spag I'm gonna go crazy because I
don't have to do any more commentary
after this match uh-huh I'm going nuts
okay let's go I'm going this to it I'm
done - bro starting off look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] low I really trying to start the
pressure on you wants to be able to get
that lead early on again that when
tokuma has no be out for three in a row
hey man Hawaii's feeling himself he
doesn't give a [ __ ] oh here we go again
this up getting it counter it down
forward to beating out the low it will
it be that go slap it on him follow up
here are you trying to kill him right
there yeah try to end it but look at his
patience oh man the jab I like it yeah
low I blame the control game I'm doing
it before you get too far me too as well
always honey and he answer back
he's trying to help them and that's the
thing is we've got to remember in this
matchup there is not gonna be a chance
for a why Sonny to get a pure death
combo there are no walls available yes
and he's gonna have to need a lot of
meter to be able to get that much damage
yes and of course if you guys are not
aware there was a recent enough to
defeat as well but nice block on that
down for sweet and look at the damage
machine here this is it to me but never
mind dr. combo nice keeping that
pressure but a low pairing here from
boys yeah going the other way not gonna
do too much damage because of the low
parry yeah but still able to get some
pressure and some meter down which is
key and right now look at that he's
almost sitting on the full part here yes
if he touches of he's done oh oh he used
it oh my gosh he try to jab him again oh
my god strike oh no we're having go low
I 2 rounds up low high trying to flip
the script here he's now on to round
straight but infinite edges working for
him and if there's no time to go in it's
now he could end it here without having
Akuma having another meter oh my god
that down forward to perfect timing from
low high knowing when the way Sonny was
to come in gets the surf ride damage
what's the mix-up here he could end it
if he gets another launch here oh he
getting back turn it's not gonna kill
though I was safe
what's the mix-up one more hit could do
it he wants his three straight rounds is
he gonna get it so convincing hair yes
he brought you barmy others give you low
high three runs straight buck and that's
the thing there he knew that would have
killed him if he gotten blog but no
Weiss believes in his spacing so much he
went for that low roundhouse kick again
but now we are going to a final match
everybody oh my god guys this is the
last match of pool play if you have a
waist guys please make some noise of the
crowd
and if you guys have no height to move
into top eight please make some noise oh
that is the crowd that I'd like to see I
hope they start fighting in the crowd
not really don't do it don't do it let's
go
the abandoned temple Mock the Akuma
stage hometown advantage maybe the
finals the final match of the group
stage is here at Second World Tour
Finals Bangkok Thailand here we go guys
vs. Akuma
the tech it always happens this way why
does it always have to go to the final
matches it's the best game in the world
here we go starting off with a big
launch air gets it down for two he's
gonna get the wall good damage Hey
all the crowd is alive I love it 50% off
just the sales Oh gets the jab punished
here and now a Weiss went back he rolls
virtually even between these two put the
slide low I started to take liberties
here yep get no meats ahead for our West
lucky oh it's a wolf up not quite oh
just outside of the range yeah range
available now he's been hit by that rate
drop so many times he's gonna get hit
again nice breaking the Wumpus to throw
oh oh oh chess out of range so scary
he's threatening the slide once again
oh my god mark look at this what's gonna
happen all Benny's in back to the wall
he's gonna have to be careful goes with
a big booty like the punish their
beautiful no higher take the lead in the
set for round straight hair right now
and the barmy it was spent as well this
is rough
oh and he's gonna get launched for it
not deep enough and again that's why
it's so hard to get the clean hit on the
low kick yeah absolutely
that's a huge life deficit not 4os
without meat as well oh you had it there
you didn't let it go they did not
believe but he has range now this could
hurt all memories that never mind one
round away from clinching the top eight
spot low high one round away can you
finish it if there's any time to go into
demon mode it's now oh this is gonna
hurt
definitely high you will feel guilt some
bonito in the meanwhile goes for the
mix-up there goes with apartment he
knows every single time that he's gone
for the demon flip mix-up yeah
Lola has tried to do something and he's
gotten hit for that pop well just go to
the hockey straight off the bat no bye
no fear he's gonna get the walk he's
gonna go and that thing now he's closer
oh my gosh this is big the clutch oh
wait honey can you take it to the wall
side wall stud good oh you had a deal
with it what's the mix-up now Oh Michael
I get out of that get out of that nice
down Ford one able to land I can't do
this
I caught through this oh yeah the
counter he confirmed but not able to get
anything out there almost has a bar
meatza
rage available base drive will kill that
was so ballsy move in the top eight I'm
gonna take you out go finally it all
comes under this now just building the
meter there all the spring kick stopping
that momentum there's a slide slide ooh
Oh
standing to his trademark with punished
captive outs
we go full war carry but doesn't get the
walls flat lucky for low high oh that
could be unfortunate he does have a
slight life lead here he's gonna have to
be very careful Lori's gonna have to
play out of his mind if he wants to
exercise the steam in all this big
although she gets the punish one of the
greatest sense I've seen today but Wow
congratulations so you got to give it up
a Weiss honey a valiant effort and not
just a wife honey all the players and
all the community out of Pakistan they
really helped change the Tekken world
and this year that was insane
absolutely and say we need to replay
that show us again here it for one more
mix-up but it wasn't quite enough
the trademark low high rage arts and it
was enough to kill mug what is it what
is it with this game I am NOT gonna ever
stop loving this game and I hope
everyone that's watching at home
realizes that men we are not even the
top ain't yet this is crazy we are not
even in topping yet so I hope you guys
are enjoying this good Tekken this good
a second I'm on burnout lucky I am fine
now that's amazing so Swee I just to
summarize what happened know before and
oh let's look at where red guys this is
our top eight you guys can see it on the
screen look at the representation from
around the world
yeah this is tough man we were talking
about you know Japan wanted to bring it
they definitely brought it they had
Korea as well we have one American
player yes and that's it that's it so
yeah we're they side you got me double
check current ob3 japanese of one korean
on the loser side Osan anakim JD SIA and
lo hi
just got in there after a really really
bad start to that group but let's give a
round of applause to all 20 of our
players here representing Tekken for you
guys
absolutely amazing all these guys is so
well this year talking has been
absolutely amazing mark I'm so happy
that I was able to be here and witness
it laughs yeah and it's been such a
great time I mean our time is done but I
know we are gonna be taking a break but
I know when we get back from our break
we're gonna have a special chat with our
friends
katsu here errata and Michael Murray so
hang in there after the break I'm going
to talk to him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]